Minerals are literally everywhere, and scientists
have found that we’re accidentally creating
new ones.
But wait, do you even know what a mineral
is?
They are defined as solid substances with
a definite chemical formula, a crystalline
structure, and are naturally occurring
Remember that natural part for later.
You might have seen some of these beauties
before: amethyst, quartz, tourmaline, azurite
are all minerals … and they’re so mesmerizing.
And you can also find minerals in your grocery
store, they can be nutrients too! like sodium,
magnesium, and calcium.
Minerals aren’t just pretty to look at;
they’re essential for us humans to function
properly.
But how do minerals form?
Well, they develop when atoms of one or more
element join together and a crystalline structure
forms.
And, most importantly, minerals are forged
in nature, born in the crucible of the Earth’s
interior!
So, when magma cools or liquids evaporate,
a mineral is born.
There are around 4,000 different types of
natural minerals!
But … according to a study published in
American Mineralogist, 208 of them, aren’t
exactly born of natural causes.
They’re here on earth ... thanks to us humans.
THESE … ARE MAN-MADE MINERALS.
Well, to clarify a bit, these minerals did
form “naturally” … but in man-made places,
like mines, smelters, and other industrial
contamination sites.
When we dig into the earth, we're opening
up areas that wouldn't naturally be there,
allowing water and air to interact with the
soil.
Industrial activities cause chemical reactions
... we’re inadvertently creating something
new when this happens.
Mineralogists are so pumped about this.
For instance, this mineral, andersonite, is
found in the tunnels of abandoned uranium
mines in the Southwest.
The sandstone that lines the tunnel walls
interacts with mine water, creating this crust
of yellow and green crystals.
Extra cool points: andersonite glows under
a blacklight.
And this pretty one Simonkolleite is found
in old copper mines.
This other newly classified mineral is Abhurite.
It was found on the not-so-happy wreck of
the SS Cheerful, a steamship that sank almost
150 years ago.
When the seawater interacts with ship’s
cargo of tin metal, Abhurite popped up.
Minerologists are calling the appearance of
these man-made minerals a “punctuation event”,
which are notable periods of time in earth's
geological record.”
Researchers are pegging this one at the start
of the industrial revolution to present day.
The first punctuation was called the Great
Oxidation event and it happened over 2 billion
years ago.
Back then, there was a massive increase in
the amount of oxygen in the atmosphere, spurring
the creation of 2/3s of the minerals we see
today.
The fact that it took only 300 years for these
man-made minerals to appear is a big deal.
We've done more to diversify minerals on the
planet in such a short period of time than
the earth has done on its own in 2 billion
years.
And that’s lead some to suggest that we’re
living in the anthropocene, or “the age
of humans.”
Some environmentalists think our impact on
the planet is so profound that a new geological
epoch needs to be declared.
But this has been hotly debated in the science
community.
It's really up to the international geologic
community to decide; they’re looking for
something called the golden spike, or a marker
in the environment that determines the start
of this new epoch.
A working group has been basically working
on this since 2009, with no answer yet.
So, these newly found minerals could be a
contender.
Whether or not these man-made rocks herald
the beginning of the age of man, it’s hard
to deny that we’re leaving a mark on this
planet.
And speaking of changing the planet, humans
might have actually caused a river to disappear!
You can learn more in this video, here.
And what about you?
Do you think these pretty rocks signal the
beginning of a new epoch?
Let us know down in the comments, don’t
forget to subscribe, and come back here for
more Seeker.